[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we
sift through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm
joined by my co-host dr
greg sadler and today we're doing a
special episode
one year in yep we have been on the air
for
a little over a year at this point and
so we thought we'd do kind of a
retrospective episode and talk about
what the show
what the show's origin was and how we
got it started and some of the things we
learned along the way and i think we'll
probably talk about a whole bunch of
other things and go off on tangents as
we also often do
right hey i love tangents
fundamental component of uh calculus and
a rather fun portion of
conversation yeah the only thing we have
to avoid is like going down
too many rabbit holes because those take
up so much time on the air
right but the good thing about them is
sometimes you can
stumble into new ideas or thoughts
you've never thought before
that's true and and oftentimes they turn
into whole episodes of their own for us
right yeah i was like oh that's really
interesting we should
hold that for something later
so what were some of the things that
that you'd wanted to talk about
in this episode i should mention too
before we get started so we
have managed during a time
of covid19 to get 31 episodes in
which i think is is quite an achievement
for two
guys who are pretty busy right
as things went on so i just wanted to
say that very quickly but that
what what what are some of the things
that you wanted to talk about in
particular
um just like some of the trials and
tribulations
and the um i know kind of like the the
successes and how we've grown i think
are the biggest things to talk about
is it too early for us to start talking
about this is glory days do we have to
like you know have the equivalence of
being out of high school for five years
or so
ah
i i feel like we couldn't even start to
call it glory years
like yeah well we don't have it it don't
think we're deep enough into it
exactly yeah we don't have we don't have
enough laurels to really
rest on we maybe just to like sit on for
a little bit right
yeah you know i really feel like i
should get some laurels
like just wear them around yeah but
those those are just for uh for show
though not for resting on
yeah like so usually what a grape leaves
and there's like oh
that's not going to support you yeah
well you know
maybe make a mesh or something right
yeah
a woven i'm not sure it's kind of funny
i don't know what the origin of that
rest on your laurels
actually is it couldn't have any sort of
physical component to it right no
so it's i actually know this one um so
laurels are
given um for uh especially during like
ancient greek times as
a a trophy for winning uh some
athletic events okay and so you'd wear
the laurels and you would
you know basically if you got those you
could go into any restaurant and you
could or
someplace to eat and people would buy
you your food or your drink and whatnot
um so it's basically the idea that you
are resting under your comp
old accomplishments without actually
doing anything so you're just like
you know i've got this reputation like i
did all these things
now i can just kind of sit around and go
like soak it in without actually having
to do anything more
so was there like an expiration date
that was based on like the laurel leaves
not drying out or anything like you
could only make this work for you first
they're super ephemeral it's not like
they could like dip them in plastic back
then
yeah so yeah like it was an ephemeral
thing i don't know i kind of
love that that was uh at least part of
the
the winnings is something that
was ephemeral that would deteriorate
over time that it wasn't
so staying as like the you know the
olympic medals that we have nowadays
oh yeah interesting yeah i suppose once
you have a medal
right you put it on your shelf and
you've got it for the next you know 40
50 years
so yeah we could say that about all
sorts of others but
let's jump into talking about the show
so
one of the things that we were going to
talk about right off the bat was
things that we've learned through doing
this this radio show
that started back in march of
uh 2020 uh shortly before the covid
crisis hit right two weeks yeah
so what did what did you learn what was
one of the things you learned um
so like part of the process was like
the the technical side and so we had to
go through uh
sit through a class and learn all the
technical bits as well as like all the
the legal bits so like oh right cannon
can't say
and what not um so there's
uh specifically the technical bits of of
running the audio equipment
that at the radio station and then you
know
once we had to move away from that
setting this up so we could continue to
do that
um from a distance away
and then um and then also then taking
this radio show that we had been
creating
and uh making it into a podcast
is distributed uh were the the big
technical
uh problems that we had to overcome and
then
unless you have something well you know
i was just gonna say
with respect to that the words you're
not allowed to say on the radio i think
we've
only had to bleep out something once the
entire
year that we've been on the air
does that sound about right or was it
was it maybe twice i mean it's been a
very miniscule
yeah great it's not like we have to a
button that we have to push all the time
or anything like that yeah yeah we've
been
uh rather good in that especially we had
a couple
of what two months ago we had the uh
am i though oh right right
is it am i the jerk right am i the jerk
episode i was like okay i can't say that
that last a there uh yeah we had to
spread around that
quite a bit didn't we yeah um but
otherwise
that was it's pretty good um and because
now that we record this beforehand
instead of being live like we were
originally
it does give us that leeway that we can
even though we're really good about it
to be able to edit it before it goes to
air
the trick though and so we're gonna
later on we're gonna do like a behind
the scenes or pulling back the curtain
but the trick with that sort of thing
just to give you a little preview
is as soon as we say something that
we're not supposed to say
we have to note the time immediately
because we can't stop recording we have
to keep on
with what we're doing and so you have to
almost
have two things going on at the same
time in your head noting
exactly when it is so that you can edit
it out later on
and continuing on with your train of
thought but i suppose there's a third
thing too like not getting not allowing
it to
derail you not you know not getting
embarrassed about it or anything like
that
not not saying yet another word another
expletive
so yeah you know i think the thing that
i learned
is it's actually in in some respects
it's easier to walk into the studio
and sit down even with all the
technology that we have to
handle and the fact that we're you know
we're under the gun to get it done right
then
it's a little bit easier to get that
done for for me because
time management is always something i
struggle with and so you know like we're
recording this
um kind of late at night which we really
need to do in part because i live
downtown and it's a little bit quieter
um river west is probably a bit quieter
at night i imagine as well
and you know making sure that we
actually
get underway get
all of the not just recording but the
editing
done so that the show can air at the
proper time
that takes a little bit more finagling
than just walking in
seating our butts in the uh stools and
and going at it
yeah did you have a similar experience
in in that respect or not
yeah uh especially because of the time i
when we
originally started this i did not have a
a regular job um that had a regular
schedule in it so
it's really nice to have something that
is very concrete in the
course of the week that like we're gonna
go there do that you know
yeah um another thing that i had
was on how to bed make a little bit
better audio
to make sure that your addiction and
enunciation
yeah are well as well as producing the
reducing the um's
those are killers um you know
i often say right at the end of things
right all those pauses yeah it's it's
it's tough i mean you can't concentrate
on that all the time
uh right because you can't you can't
have your brain totally occupied with
that
it is uh it is tough not to shift into
those especially when you're thinking
about something
and you're not always
incredibly conscious of them especially
when you're first starting to do this
because
they're part of normal speech and radio
is not
exactly normal speech patterns that's
right yeah
becoming incredibly conscious though
does happen as soon as you start editing
it
you become hyper conscious of how often
not
not just not just saying um or filler
words like that
i will say the same word twice
and i had no idea that i was i was doing
that so
often doing podcast stuff also reveals
that to you as well
yeah i think repeating the word is a lot
better than the um's
the the other thing is that you become
incredibly well versed in finding the
waveform of ums if you're editing them
out
that's true yeah we so should we jump
ahead to talking about that or
should we should we tell the backstory
let's do the backstory first
right yeah rather than getting into all
these technical weeds right off the
start
so how did how did the wisdom for life
come to being
there's a long back story both for me
and for dan
and then for both of us together on my
part
my wife and i came back to milwaukee in
2015
and shortly after that we we actually
pitched the idea of a philosophy related
show to riverwest radio
but they said oh we've got enough shows
right now but would you would you be
interested in doing some consulting work
for us
and we did it pro bono because you know
we'll talk about river west radio always
needs donations
in a bit so that's an in-kind donation
and i ended up coming on as a guest on
two different shows one about cuisine
and then one that's a little bit harder
to describe that skrauss
used to do about well we talked about
like hp lovecraft and philip dick but
but we ranged over a lot of other
topics as well so that's how i got
into that river west radio
matrix and then every once in a while
i'd run into martin at a coffee shop and
he'd say
hey uh do you think you want to do a
show sometime and and it just
the wheels never aligned properly right
that that only happens when you come
into the story
so i mean you've got a longer back
history with river breast radio why
don't you say a little bit about that
yeah so um i i was i've lived in river
west
off and on for the last i know uh
over a decade now and you know i saw the
the rise of river west radio um i
remember early on
uh like zav one of the runners of it
with martin um had like a tp that he set
up
on outside so it kind of gives you kind
of the feel of
the the neighborhood that is kind of
like bohemian
and a little bit odd in just the right
ways and
um once i came back
after college and uh after a stint out
in california
um i had
at that time and that point in time i
had already
started to get kind of deep into stoke
philosophy and that's how i
eventually met up with greg at
the milwaukee stoke fellowship which he
was running i remember
on coming in and i was so new that like
i
often the doors like is this the cynics
you know this is stoics
oh yes that's the one i forgot about
that yeah
yeah we we founded this stoic fellowship
which is a branch of
a much larger worldwide set of
organizations right
and um what we do is we get together
and it used to be just once a month but
actually dan expanded it considerably
with with these stoic walk-in talks
you you got that idea from one of the
bay area
the fremont stokes okay right right yeah
and and so
at first that was going to
which park was it mostly lake park
that's right yeah and and
walking around and talking about marcus
aurelius or epictetus and
chatting for a while and so then you
know inclement weather turned it into a
coffeehouse kind of thing and then covid
forced it into uh zoom
just like our regular meetup and so dan
and i got to know each other
quite well uh through going to these
these stoic fellowships at one point we
were actually
talking about doing uh like a summer
camp thing
which you know kovitt would have thank
god we didn't start planning
because really put the kavash on that
but um yeah i remember sitting in i
think it was in my car
and we started talking about doing a
show right
so it was we were kind of like
footballing ideas of like is there a
project to do
and uh one of them was the radio show i
was just like oh yeah that seems great
hey look
there's a radio station that is uh
right for us to go and uh be a part of
and
it kind of built up from there i guess
we looked online to see like what was
the process to actually
sign up and become part of the group and
that's that's a cool feature of river
west radio that we'll talk about in just
a bit
it is it is definitely community radio
so
they're open to all sorts of show ideas
obviously there's some that they'll say
ah we've got enough of those like sports
shows or
i think music shows but when it comes to
putting philosophy
online out there in the internet there's
there's kind of a lack of that
and especially with with practical
philosophy i mean there are philosophy
shows where it's kind of academic-y
and you know what does hume have to say
about causality do we really know
anything you know about about cause and
effect for sure
that's got some practical effects but
but it's pretty abstract right the sort
of stuff that we're
engaging a little bit ahead in the
clouds there yeah yeah
um so i mean the stuff that we're
providing
it was to be things that could reach
ordinary people right
and be beneficial that's right yeah and
useful specifically
so so we started getting together and i
i think we talked about it
for at least a couple months before we
actually
we you know we were taking steps we do
we were doing research
but before we actually contacted um
martin and zav you and i had kicked
around some ideas at coffee houses
mostly
um where else
uh downtown at the fister hotel oh
that's right yeah yeah that was fun
i didn't realize you know i live right
downtown
and i didn't realize that these these
older hotels have
all sorts of what would you call them
auxiliary things basic amenities
yeah exactly for for the people who are
there but but they're
they're anyone could walk in and make
use of them
like uh there was that nice cafe that we
went to
and then you showed me it wasn't quite a
museum but it was a display thing
oh yes because they have the um they
have an artist in residence
that's right yeah and and they have a
place where they work which is also
has play glass windows so you can see
the work that working on so
sometimes it's um sculptures sometimes
it's
um uh what are they i don't know
seamstress seems less than
what i mean but like an artist that
creates clothes textiles
yeah okay yeah you know i think someday
we should actually
once covet is done we should actually do
a show about
all the cool things that you can access
for free
in milwaukee and you might feel a little
bit like when you're walking in like i'm
not sure if i belong here
but they won't kick you out or you can
kind of have an interesting
time because that was that was a good
example of that
um and then then we we signed up
and as dan was saying a little bit
earlier we had to do some training
we had to do uh two weekend workshops
where
we learned how to work the the board and
you know all the ins and outs of
microphones and headphones and
a lot of other administrivia kind of
stuff right
how to make a show work and then there
was all the content related things about
what not to say what to say how to
i don't know how to be appealing maybe
is
how to not go over time especially when
you're live yeah
i don't have to get to the point where
they'll cut you off
i think that the was it the first of the
second episode
zob comes running out from the back and
like goes like
i think it was the first one yeah i
think it was our first episode
i've totally forgotten about that yeah
it's like there's 30 seconds before the
end of the hour you must end
yeah and then they told us in the in the
workshop that they they were going to do
that
and we somehow it escaped our mind or
something like that so then you know the
uh the only other thing that we we
really had to do was we needed some show
music for the intro and the outro
and i got a friend and colleague of mine
scott truly
who i i also do a a metal show with
he's a great guitarist and he i asked
him would you would you do a
a clip for us and he didn't even you
know say
how much how much do you want to pay me
or anything like that he was like no
that'll be cool you know i'll
i'll do it for you and then he's like
what kind of stuff do you want i said i
don't know kind of joe satrianiesque
and that's that's what we got i mean you
heard it at the top of the hour and
you'll hear it
and you'll heard at the end as well
exactly yeah
so and we actually use that as like our
bracket
for when we're when we're doing things
live right
it fades in it fades out at the the
top and the bottom of the hour but we
also use that for framing things
in the way that we're doing things now
yeah so if
if we're doing it live and we need to
cut out the audio
we always have a backer track that we
can bring up
and so if usually you haven't heard that
in a very long time
but uh if there's any point in time
where like we need to
talk amongst ourselves we'll just bring
out the music and
it's always behind us just so you don't
hear it
yeah and you know with river west radio
because it is in river west and as dan
was mentioning it's it's a real
really unique kind of neighborhood in
the old radio station you could have
people
walking in off the street and wanting to
contribute to your show whether they
were
you know whether it was planned or not
so that might be
a case for you to jack down the mics and
boost up the music for a little bit and
give people a little preview of
i don't know some other tracks right
right right
um and so if you want please uh go check
out uh
scott um we've always got our link in
the show notes
you know we should put a pitch right now
too um
i know exactly yeah yeah and so
let's talk briefly before we hit people
up
for making contributions about why river
west radio is so important right give
give them some value before we
extract some value yeah
[Laughter]
so uh
i guess what is our focus you know what
is the
the idea behind the show why is it so
important and
what are we going to be doing with it
well
so wisdom for life it took us a while to
pick out that name
but we wanted something that embodied
the fact that we're focusing on life
we're focusing on practical things and
that we're bringing philosophy to bear
and it's not just philosophizing for the
sake of philosophizing
but in order to live live better you
know so to improve our relationships or
develop a uh better understanding of who
we are
and how to you know improve ourselves
all of those sorts of
things but greg i thought naval gazing
was this
chief uh idea behind philosophy isn't it
well you know
when i was younger i could navel gaze a
lot easier
but now i'm older and fatter and you
know
it takes a little bit of work to do that
no no i mean there are i think there are
a lot of people who get into philosophy
and they're looking for something like
what you're calling naval gazing they're
they're using it in kind of a
narcissistic way to
really focus on themselves where
they're the main object and everybody
else should like listen to them or think
about what they
they have to say but that's really
boring stuff
i mean i've had people like that in
seminars and
after a while you're like oh man just
sit down and shut up
sooner or later people want something
that's that's going to speak to them
and has something you know something
they can use to
maybe fix parts of their life or improve
parts that are going well or just
understand
themselves a little bit better right
yeah
i mean actually this is kind of a good
jumping off point
so the fremont stoics you know we you
and i have talked about this a bit
what was it that drew you to hanging out
with those
those people they probably weren't all
like professional academic philosophers
right
but they were very interested in
stoicism
and i imagine other schools of
philosophy as well
how were the what were they doing
i guess i i went to them because they
were the crows
i was living in oakland at the moment
and so they were the the closest group
that
met regularly like there was uh um
one up in uh marin and then one in san
francisco
but they were like meeting once a month
bar these guys were they were meeting
every week and so okay that
scratched my itch and that's why i went
there um
and also we walked around lake elizabeth
in fremont which is uh
you know a beautiful park and like uh
can't
you know be unhappy with that situation
um and uh
you know they're mostly interested in
stoicism
um that's but like i guess i i took that
because i was there
uh and once i came back i wanted to
reproduce that a little bit there must
have been something that they were
providing
in their conversations that made you
want to come back
not just the beautiful lake but
something about the way they're doing
things
i imagine there's you know obviously
community
um and uh the ability to have
to create those
meaningful meaningful discussions in
order to actually get
deeper into a topic and we can you know
read all these things
and we're still kind of stuck on our
heads and unless we have something to
bounce some ideas off of and try to you
know like
i think this is this is moral and that
kind of like
fits into a certain moral world view
and uh it's always good to have someone
there to
you know uh call you on your bs
you know you in in the right way right
not
not just to be a nit picker or to
um be a professional critic or something
like that
or or even to be like i'm gonna you know
i'm i'm gonna be your physical trainer
i'm gonna just punch you a lot and
you'll get tougher that way
right but somebody who they don't have
to care about you
like you know you're you're the friend
who's the the
you know one soul and two bodies sort of
stuff right but they they actually like
treat you as a person and regard you as
as being important
you know that's something that i think a
lot of people are missing
in their lives i you know i get people
who say oh you know i i want to study
philosophy
i'm stuck doing it on my own because
there's nobody else that i can
really talk to about this sort of stuff
and i you know so groups like that i
think are
pretty important or if you're if you're
inclined towards that's
that sort of thing having friends that
you can engage with is is
often very valuable as well
go ahead it goes into like building
practices
like you're doing this thing you're
talking about these things and
the the end result is that you're like
starting to instill in yourself
better practices that lead you to a
little bit more calmer state of mind of
the
ability to look at things in a
more nuanced and broad way to not be
overwhelmed by certain things and these
were all benefits
that you know we have brought into the
show to a certain extent of talking
about what are the benefits
um for your mental state as well as your
your social state
through philosophy yeah there were some
other things that
that we'd wanted to talk about like with
the the general idea of the show and i
think that some of these
actually came out of what we did rather
than like being things that we
originally
settled on so one of the things i
identified was
veering off into current issues so we
ended up for example talking about
protests and policing and the social
contract and
black lives matter and things along
those lines
um because we felt that it was important
and then you know we've also been going
to topics that are of
you might say evergreen or perennial
interest
as well and i think we originally we had
in mind well we're going to talk about
tho
those the latter more right we're going
to try to make sure that every episode
is something that could be played
10 years from now but i think we
actually got a lot out of talking about
what was happening in the world
and in in milwaukee um
yeah i would agree that you know even
though that
it's going to be at least topical it the
that was just like the state of of the
conversation
and then the rest of the conversation is
is still an
evergreen topic that these issues
are you know constant and uh
[ __ ] and and change over time but like
they
it's just the the current incarnation of
them
okay yeah yeah that's that that makes a
lot of sense
um there was another thing that you had
in here that i thought was was
kind of cool um the familiarity of
friends enjoying each other's company so
that's us right yeah okay yeah
absolutely
like uh i've heard a number of times
people have responded in comments it's
like you know it's really nice
it seems like you are just two old
friends uh
having a really good conversation with
each other yeah rather than like radio
hosts who like
walk in not at each other and then put
on their shtick right
right so here's an interesting question
for you do you think that's been
aided by the fact that we haven't been
in the studio
and we've had to do all this technical
finagling
um you know because we before we'd
when we'd go into the studio we'd we'd
chit-chat before that right and we'd
sometimes
do that afterwards but here we we never
start recording at
at the given point in time that we're
coming on we always chat for about half
an hour or so and catch up and
um i don't know i feel like
there wasn't enough data points to
actually make a distinction
like there were literally two episodes
that we did in the radio show before
lockdown happened yeah uh but at least
one of those we
preceded it by going to the coffee shop
next door
and we had a you know a good time having
some coffee and
went over our notes for what we were
expecting to go over in the episode
and i don't know like we don't have
the other example to
compare it to so i i don't know if it it
has or has not
yeah it'll be interesting to see when we
inevitably get to go back
to the the station you know whatever
that's going to be
so go ahead i said only one safe enough
that's it
yeah so let's talk about river west
radio um they're the ones who are
hosting this they they gave us a home
for this this show
they are a community radio station and
that's something kind of unique there's
not a lot of those
out there and a lot of people mix up
community and public radio so i think we
should talk about the
differences between those you know
everybody's familiar with
you know whatever their state public
radio is or npr
national public radio we're kind of
fortunate here in wisconsin and that
we've got
quite a few you know and they they
perform a really valuable role they have
cool shows
and sometimes they can be very local but
they're not as local as community radio
right now yeah the community radio
program
was early 2000s when i say it was uh
kind of put into place
and it allowed a lot of people
access to actually broadcasting that
weren't
wouldn't be able to do that and so
almost all of them were only given
permits for low power and so they're
you know a much lower radius in which
they
can operate on the fm dial
um but you know riverwest radio
in the the age of technology that you
are you know you can
ask your uh alexa or google home to
do whatever it just like asks them for
rare west radio and it'll pop right up
anywhere in the world
as well as going to their website yeah
you know that's kind of an interesting
thing so when when it was originally put
in place
i don't think people had in mind that it
would be streaming over the internet
right
right they're kind of like well we'll
let them have this little tiny
scrap
[Laughter]
community radio can be as big as any of
the
commercial affiliates if enough people
listen to it
right uh and it just it
opened up the opportunity for people
that would
usually never have the ability or the
accents to run their radio station
to like just take the reins and go and
do crazy new things
yeah you know so zav and martin the
the people who run river west radio
they i don't want to say that they have
less work to do because they actually
have a lot more work to do in many
respects but they're doing a very
different kind of work than station
managers would be doing
for you know npr or a commercial radio
station
in that they you know that that
proverbial herding cats i think that
they're doing a lot of that
um and they're not doing it because
they've got all these divas or you know
big
big uh performers who are coming on but
rather because
it is community radio so shows are
entrusted
to people to produce
not not just to be hosts of but to
plan out to carry out all the production
and there's kind of a big big um
what would you call it like there's
there's a big promise and trust
that that's going on every time that
somebody comes on the air
that you're not going to say stuff that
the fcc is going to have a problem with
and you're going to produce good content
that people will be interested in you're
going to have if you're going to do a
show that requires research you're going
to have done it
and i think they've been pretty you know
pleasantly
i don't know if they're surprised or not
but they're you know the shows are good
there's there's a lot of really great
content on on river west radio
yeah and and
most people are doing this um basically
for free
so there's not like this uh monetary
motivation
to do this this is kind of like a labor
of love that people
love their radio station and the
opportunity to have their voice be
projected is enough
to get them to go but you know because
there isn't
some like it's a job it is a little bit
of hurting cats as you said
yeah i i they put in a lot of
work those those guys um and then so do
show producers you know i mean
each show um like we come up with a
script
kind of i mean it's it's actually it's
not much of a script it's a bunch of
bullet points right
but some of the shows you know really go
into a lot of
work and and they use all the sound
effects and things like that and
um nobody's actually making anything off
of that
it's all a service for the river west
community the milwaukee community and
the larger
world community so yeah
so we should make an appeal at this
point in time now that we've talked up
uh riverwest radio
and community radio do you want to do it
dan or you want me to do it
oh i think we could both do it riverwest
radio uh
wxrw 104.1
lpfm in milwaukee
[Laughter]
is community radio and produces
uh our show as well as a plethora of
other
music news and politics
radio shows for the community of
riverwest and
for the world yeah they're really doing
a lot of great work and
it's very easy to donate there's a
donate
button on the website that we're putting
a link to
in here for westradio.com exactly so
you know if you chip in just uh you know
five bucks 10 bucks whatever you know
you you think is
is adequate you're actually helping
to provide a basis for you know
episode after episode after episode of
of great shows and keeping
keeping something that's really unique
here in milwaukee
running and producing
yeah it's a great resource and uh
i hope that you enjoyed us enough that
you might
uh help the people that help us bring it
to you yeah
that's that's a good pitch i think
so let's talk a little bit of history uh
we've mentioned this a couple times
we got two episodes in and then kovit
hit
and there is a kind of story that we've
told before but i think a lot of
listeners might not know
about how our show was the very last
show
that went live in the studio
right so we did our first show
everything was copacetic and all of it
you know the rumblings of
of foreboding things to come
um and you know things are some places
are shutting down but there's no like
overall shutting down and
it comes to i think we're friday at what
four
four to five i think we did uh yeah that
was a great
spot yeah
it was ideal yeah how the heck did we
walk into that i don't know um but we we
go to the door and it's
was it locked when we got there no
we got in and then they locked the door
behind us
and i thought that's weird yeah
and we're getting up there to like set
up and they're like
what didn't you get the email no that
came after oh
okay we did the whole show they they
looked at us weird and
we i get maybe look back at him weird
but it was our second show
so we're like well maybe they're not
used to us being in here or
you know and so we sat down and we we
did our show
and then and then i think it was off
came up to us afterwards he said you
know the station's closed right
and we're like what yeah yeah apparently
they had sent
out a mass email to all of their show
producers
but uh there was a snafu and our
emails were not put on that list
because we were so new that's what it
was yeah
and so they they were wondering what the
hell we were doing walking in there
but they were cool with it you know they
rolled with it and yes let us do that
that second episode
which was about uh handling fear in a
pandemic right
right so maybe they thought we were
doing like a public service or something
that was a public service of course it
was yeah but we should
we should listen to that one and see
what our advice was back then
yeah a year into it and figure it out
so anyway they said you know uh well
we're closing down now we're not sure
what we're gonna do
and the the kicker was it's just too
difficult
to disinfect everything that's involved
in
radio you got the mics and you could
you'd have to like swap out mic covers
for every single show
but the biggest killer is the uh the
board
the uh there's like over 100 little
switches on the board
yeah there's no way you could you could
disinfect that so
so you know it was a while before how
long was it before we
figured out that we could do this a
couple months
i think it was less than that i think it
was a month at most okay
i know that they did some shows by
having people call in
right and then now they're using zoom
themselves right for other shows
um yes yes
uh some so yeah so
they're doing it live that way yeah but
i think we've
really enjoyed the ability to record
whenever
and not be under that exact timeline we
figured out an mo
that works really good for us and
creates the sort of things that
that we want and gives us enough control
over the quality
so we i've got this section peeling back
the curtain
where i thought we would tell them about
how how we actually do this
yeah okay so we have a
59 minute hard limit because this is
first and foremost
a radio show and it has to fit into
the fcc dictated constraints
uh there has to be one minute of station
identification
every hour and so we must fit into
a time limit that is dictated by the
format
or the medium of a radio show so right
now we each have a stopwatch
on our computers and we're watching that
sometimes uh you know we we get pretty
close to the to the limit
but but most times we we managed to pull
it off
yeah and then uh
we at least back in the the times we
were in it we had
our the board we had to like bring out
the the
uh intro bring down all the levels bring
up the things
but now it's like we we go over our
notes
we um clap our hands so we can
synchronize the audio once we go into
the editing and we uh dan does his
countdown
yes i go three if you can see it's on
youtube three two
and then go and and we start the show uh
and we click our our timer at that point
in time so we
know exactly where we are in the show
and we try to follow our script as best
as we can
yeah which is usually not all that well
we we often have more content than we we
get to
but we're actually right now each of us
is recording on
our end using this free software called
audacity which which works pretty well
and we use it for for editing
and we're looking at each other using
zoom
so zoom is recording the video
and its own audio track but we're not
using the audio track from zoom because
it's not good enough
we're you know we want it to be as as
close to studio quality as possible
so audacity affords that to us and then
we take
um we take the ants track we take my
track we you know beef them up a little
bit
try to you know improve the audio as
much as possible and then edit them
together into one
big master track and then put the show
music
at the beginning and end and then we
have a podcast episode which
goes to uh martin and zav at the station
and it plays at our designated hour so
there's there's actually a lot
involved in there's there's more i would
say involved in the producing of the
show
now on our end than there was when we
could do it in studio right and then
we we also then put it to other places
we actually make a podcast
right right um so i i run the
the podcast distribution uh side of it
and so i
throw it up to our feed and send it out
to all of you people
um and then greg uh makes a youtube
video out of it
yeah and i'll tell you a little trick
too sometimes the zoom
and the audio track they don't match up
exactly and so i got to do a little bit
of cutting here and there
and stretching things out to make it fit
so
if you're if you're ever watching it and
it doesn't look
exactly like the words
are mapped on to our mouths perfectly
well that's aliens i'm sorry oh yeah
peel back the uh the reptilian masks yes
these things don't sink perfectly you
know and uh you know
it's it's one of the challenges of these
these technological platforms
you know it's really good when we give
you the impression that everything
is going off totally without a hitch but
trust me nothing's ever happening that
way behind the scenes
yeah ah but the end product is
pretty dang good if i say so my myself
and hey you're here that's that's a
perfect segue
into um favorite episodes
if if you know which which do you think
we're particularly
good or fun or however else you wanna
whatever else what goes into making it
your favorite so
i think um the circles of connection and
care
was one of the first episodes where i
was like
i felt like was one of the first that we
hit our stride that was one of the first
i was like
i was really happy about that and that
was the one early
on that would say hey um i do have this
radio show
if you're interested i suggest you
listen to this episode first
that one was our i think early high
watermark
that's a good criterion um
that could be something like on a quiz
like if you had to pick one episode
to recommend a show you know
that's actually a great way to look at
it um
it was one of yours well i i really like
the future of work one that we did
where we were talking about i mean
something that
is going to happen i mean we live in
this they now talk about the precariat
you know people who are
stuck working gig jobs or moving from
one job to the next
and that's more and more becoming the
way work
gets divvied out to us and then we've
got all the developments with ai
and robotics and logistics
and you know we could be looking at a
point in time not that far from now
where a lot of the things that we think
of as jobs have been
phased out you know or assigned to
someone else so what do we do then
in in that situation i thought we had a
really great show on that that's that's
actually a topic we could probably hit
again though
oh yeah there's so many in the the
intersection of
you know human human well-being and
technology that
uh is right for dissection yeah
uh so another one that i love you know
wasn't too long ago but was the
uh am i the jerk
am i the jerk otherwise known as aita
on a q a session we kind of like one of
the things that
uh greg is well known for is like
it's okay to make moral judgments and
you need to be able to back up those
moral judgments and so we kind of went
through these
questions of am i the jerk and and
kind of walk through our uh reason
making for making certain world
judgments based on
real world experiences i think we should
do another one of those
maybe multiple ones there's so many in
the the reddit aita
forum that we'd never run out of them
and they they really are
great moral dilemmas you know
there was another one that i
particularly liked from a technical
aspect as well as a content
aspect and that's the one that we just
recently did
with john sellers although john sellers
wasn't
on the air with us at the time we
i did an interview with john sellers
who's somebody really big in the
philosophy's way of life
community and then we took that and i
played it
i played the clips of the interview on
my phone
while we were engaging in
in the radio show and then of course i
patched them in uh
using using our editor uh later on
and it was sort of like john was here
but but not here and so it gave us the
capacity to bring in
an expert guest so i i thought that was
that was uh
pretty cool that we could actually pull
it off
[Laughter]
and that was us like listening to him
live so it was
it was really well done splicing in
yeah and i think we could do more of
those in the future because you know
we're not going to get people to want to
record with us at nine o'clock in the
evening
especially if that translates to three
in the morning there
uh yeah but i think we could bring in a
lot more
interesting guests like that don't you
yeah
i think it's uh something to definitely
pursue yeah
well we were going to talk about um some
of the practices but maybe we won't do
that we've got some other things that
that we
wanted to talk about we'll see if we
have time to to get to some of these
these practices so
another thing we were going to we were
going to hit on is where we thought we'd
be at this time when we started the show
obviously covid threw a huge monkey
wrench into things
like uh personally i
i didn't know i i was living pretty
kind of like week to week at the moment
i didn't have a really regular job
at the moment yeah and
and everything has changed for me from
my employment to
uh to running things within the
communities that i run
and for relationships it's it's like a
whole different ballgame i like i
couldn't even say
where i thought i was going to be
because uh and then you just throw in
covet and that's just
yeah yeah the entire world is in a a
place that would have been
entirely alien to me you know
i think that originally we were planning
on doing the show
every week friday during drive time you
know four to five
and we'd made that commitment and then
you know
we got those two shows in and then we
had a down time for a while and then
during the summer
we were able to do like a show a week
um but then yeah you got a lot busier i
got a lot busier with the semester
starting and we we started doing a
new show like every other week most of
the time
but we still managed to get 31 episodes
done and i think that's kind of a
significant achievement 31 good episodes
you know we there's not a single one
where i'd be like well
that's just filler or anything like that
we've explored a lot of really uh
interesting and and important topics
and a lot of them of course we can go
back and there's more to say about them
but i think
we we did produce a lot of of
really quality content and then you know
the shift i mean we were i was bringing
in my my camera and i would video record
us
in the studio but i think doing this
and like you said having the podcast as
well we've we've got some really
stable content you know this is going to
be out there
for decades to come so
it's kind of a cool legacy one year in
it isn't actually what i thought we'd be
doing
quite quite frankly i thought i thought
it was gonna be more
there'd be you know the recordings but
it'd just be more live
you know interacting you know from from
four to five each week and
and i'm i'm actually kind of happy with
the direction that things have taken
yeah what do you think um if we go back
to the studio
do you want to go back to the studio or
is this a more conducive
workflow for you i do want to go back to
the studio because i
i'm i'm a pretty extroverted person so i
like
getting out i enjoy chatting with people
especially if we can get that four to
five uh p.m
time slot back you know yeah that'd be
pretty awesome because that's you know
like prime driving hour
um i wonder if we could get
uh two gopros so we could still have
like the the double close-up on the
faces
that would be really cool actually
that's something well worth thinking
about
um how to do the in studio
stuff better you know right that's
yeah that that's something i haven't
devoted any time there's any thought to
at this point so speaking of of
you know surprises like open was a big
surprise what were some of the biggest
surprises that you've had
in the past year doing this radio show
so for me
i think it has to do with the videos of
it
um people really like to watch
what to me seems to be pretty static
content it's it's you and me as heads
essentially
right when we're in the studio sitting
sitting in place
um you know we gesticulate a lot right
we
we're both hand talkers but um and i
think we have you know
adequate expressions on our face but
it's still not like
very dramatic is it i mean it's mostly
you and me talking
people really like to watch that sort of
stuff
to the to the extent that you know our
first couple times that we tried doing
this the zoom
recording didn't work right so there's
kind of a gap in the in the video
stuff i think the we're missing like
episode three four and then maybe five
and six
and people will pester me about those oh
yeah
you know why are you holding back
episode three
i'm not holding it back i just don't
have it we stuck it with the
ark of the covenant and exactly yeah so
that's kind of a
good idea but if you are looking for
those
they're on the podcast feed you can join
this right right yeah
you can hear them at least yeah so what
about
so for me is like uh doing this and then
um hearing back from other creators who
i
was enamored with like i was a fan of
their work and hearing back that they
had also listened to my work
and and said like they enjoyed it so
this was specifically
matt banetta who is a podcaster and
author
and i was uh
moderating a uh
what is it called a stoic count x yes
but
specifically just uh oh panel just right
and he was he was on the panel and i was
just doing my due diligence to make sure
everyone was able to
be presented as they would like to be
presented
and you know started that conversation
so he
gave me the compliment back so it's it's
nicer like oh i've produced something
that someone else
that i think is worthy of
um enjoying their work to have that
reciprocity
yeah that's pretty cool because he he's
a big heavy hitter in the stoic
podcast community he had the good
fortune podcast
that um i mean that was that's been
around for quite a while
yeah um what 2017 maybe
i think it goes back before that
it was it was something that turned a
lot of people on to stoicism
yeah he he's got a really nice way of
presenting some really
basic ideas uh in a really
straightforward
and easy to grasp way yeah
well let's talk about some some topics
that
we would like to do in the future
yeah a little bit of uh
planning things out you know and if
you're a listener you know
and and you are listening to this on on
the podcast or the video you can always
like
shoot an email to us and say hey we want
to see more of this or more
more of you that or read the comments
exactly so what are what are some of the
things that you want to
hit on that we haven't we might have
delved into but we didn't get into
directly yeah so uh one of our next
topics that we're going to get into is
meaning
and that's that's a big topic that would
probably be many many episodes
um and uh technology the good life
how does uh our technology either help
or hinder us and
what would be the criteria that we need
to put on
those things that are in our lives in
order to
determine if it is actually a benefit or
a detriment to us
yeah and how to turn things that maybe
we recognize
have been a detriment for a while either
if we're not going to get rid of them
all together how to use them in ways
that would be beneficial
for us right right i i'd like to do some
more deep dive
shows about philosophical practices we
did that one about
negative visualization and i think it
would be cool
you know actually the circles of concern
was also like a deeper dive one too
you know so i think it'd be it'd be nice
to do more like that where we devoted
whole hour to one particular practice
and
really give a lot of examples about how
to do it well you know
anything else you know i i do a lot of
work on anger management
um maybe we can shout at each other on
the air a bit
you know are you i'm so
angry at you greg yeah i i i think it
would be
kind of cool to go into that maybe maybe
other emotions too i think
we did a show exact on anxiety right a
while back
so maybe there's some others as well
maybe something beneficial
joy or zest oh right that's that's
actually a great
idea because that came up in the stoicon
thing
so we're getting to the top of the hour
i think we
probably have to cut it short at this
point right
uh yeah unless there's i just
the the practice of like learning to
trust your co-host to like how
to interact with them is someone that's
very
useful but um thank you greg for being
my co-host
oh thank you and thanks for you know
all the work that you've put in on this
as well thank you
so we leave you with the words of j.r.r
tolkien the road goes ever
on and on down from the door where it
began
now far ahead the road has gone and i
must follow
if i can pursue it with eager feet
until it joins some larger way with many
paths and aaron's meet and whether then
i cannot say
[Music]
you